bill maher was on joe rogan a day or two
ago and they discussed a lot of this and
where marr is at when it comes to saying
he's a liberal who the people he's
voting for are
and what is going on with the crazy left
so here uh i think you'll see he
actually makes some sense to me you know
you're don't you think you've gotten
more conservative no i haven't the left
has gotten goofier yes so i seem more
conservative maybe
but like
it's not me who changed yeah i feel i'm
the same guy but five years ago
uh
you know we hadn't spent six trillion
dollars
to stay home five years ago no one was
talking about abolishing
the police
you know there was no talk about uh
you know
pregnant men and you know i mean there
was
looting was still illegal right yeah
you know and they're crazy there was
just there's so like have i changed no
because if someone had said 20 years ago
i i'm not sure looting is a bad thing i
would have opposed it then see i so i
haven't changed
okay so bill and your peeps who may or
may not be watching i want to give
credit there right you actually haven't
changed that much your brand of
liberalism which is a brand of
liberalism that is is quite worthy it is
the same classical liberalism that this
country was founded upon individual
rights equality for all
these are good ideas using logic and
reason to solve problems the government
shouldn't do absolutely everything
these are good ideas and actually in
many ways you have not changed uh but he
says the left has gotten goofier now of
course that is correct the the
progressive movement which is wildly
ill-liberal
has destroyed liberalism and this is
where i think the disconnect comes with
bill so okay if you're a good liberal
but everyone on your side of the aisle
all the people that you've promoted on
your show all the candidates that you've
supported all the democrats in essence
if you've always gone with those people
and then suddenly you look around and
you go boy 90 of the people that i
associate with are completely insane and
are ushering in bad ideas he lists out a
few of them say abolish the police or
men can get pregnant or that looting
should suddenly be legal all of these
things if it's all of the people that
call themselves liberals or call
themselves lefties then although you may
not have changed perhaps there is
something wrong with the root idea of
liberalism and this is not something as
i've said before that i that i come to
lightly as someone that has considered
myself a liberal my entire life the the
basic ideas of a john stewart mill
liberalism of thomas jefferson
liberalism
those ideas that ushered in this country
are
basically the right ideas but perhaps
now they're missing something perhaps in
an age of massive intolerance and this
woke disease perhaps liberalism because
it puts tolerance above all else well
faux tolerance i should say
perhaps that weak underbelly has allowed
intolerance to come in so this is a
problem so you can sit there and say
i am a liberal still
but if everyone that you vote for
meaning democrats right the guy has
never voted for a republican he'll tell
you he hates critical race theory but
although he doesn't live in virginia did
he publicly support glenn yonkin he'll
tell you that florida is doing
everything right
but he makes a point of what he's saying
but i'm not going to move to florida and
he won't say that he's going to support
ron desantis so this is the disconnect
that the last liberals have and here
today i am coming i am coming open
and welcoming that it's time for you
guys to get on board
it's time enough's enough it is time to
get on board so if you think i'm making
it up that that
conservatives generally have been
warning about these things and usually
write about these things so the same
liberal position now is that lockdowns
are bad and actually men can't give
birth in a bunch of it but conservatives
and and it's not even conservative it's
just sane people like it's really not
liberal versus conservative anymore it's
basically people with a completely
insane set of views
versus people with some sane set of
views and we may disagree on
you know some where those parameters are
at exactly but roughly sane people
versus awful insane people okay
uh
the same people have been right about a
lot they've been right about the
lockdowns they've been right about what
was coming with the gender stuff they've
been right about what was coming with
critical race theory and everything else
you may remember this clip on bill
maher's very show
two years ago when dennis prager went on
to say
in essence that soon the left will be
saying or they're saying it already but
it's really coming that men will be able
to menstruate here we go the left wing
is infinitely larger than one person i
don't choose one left wing person who
tells a lie
the left wing says i'll give you
gigantic lies that the united states is
a racist country this this is a lie this
is a gargantuan lie this is the least
racist multi-cultural multi-ethnic
country in the history of the world that
these people believe it is proof to me
about how effective lying
this is an unbelievably non-racist
country have you people been to asia or
they have something
of course there's i'm a jew okay there
are anti-semites in america it is a
giant lie that america is anti-semitic i
taught jewish history at brooklyn
college i know it i wrote two books on
judaism this is the least anti-semitic
country jews have ever lived in to say
america's anti-semitic is a lie to say
it is racist is a lie okay these are
giant left-wing lies we're talking about
degrees to say that men can menstruate
is a lie and that is now that is what is
said
yes wait wait wait where did that i
never said you've never heard it right
okay check it out folks check it out i
think anyone who says
not menstruate what's considered
transphobic i i i missed this whole
story
i did
not tell me where
are you getting just google it can then
menstruate who is saying this you're
talking very small
really that how do you allow men
biological men to run against women in
in the races in connecticut and set all
the high school records okay i know but
that's what they they're called men the
nation
they're they're women so dennis prager
was warning about all of this stuff and
of course when he says that the country
is the least racist country ever bill
bill says well there's some racism but
of course it's just a meaningless
position it is a meaningless position to
say there is some racism in america
there is some racism everywhere and bill
uh dennis's response
have you gone to asia i mean guys you
should do a little googling if you like
to google or whatever search end you use
about the inter
racist attitudes asian people have about
other asian people from country to
country it's rather extraordinary how
the chinese feel about the japanese how
the japanese feel about the taiwanese
how the oh the whole thing the koreans
feel about this that the other okay um
the idea that we are the racist when we
have relentlessly fought over the
hundreds of years of our country to
eliminate racism and we pretty much
almost got there until the last couple
years where the left is bringing it back
but the audience feels very
uncomfortable they're good liberals we
must be racist we're good liberals we
have to be bad we feel guilty because
we're successful and decent we must be
racist not us though it's those other
people it's those other crazy right-wing
people so of course
dennis is completely right about that
and exposes it uh and then when he
brings up the gender stuff
and this thing about women menstruating
bill says well i missed that story and
dennis says no it's happening right now
and he brings up the point that we now
all know like what have we been talking
about for the last couple months about
this endless assault assault it's the
only word to use of women when it comes
to women's sports and now biological men
leah thomas destroying all of these
actual girls because he's not a girl
in women's swimming
dennis says look it up dennis says look
it up when bill is so shocked that
people could be saying this about
menstruation well you're not going to
believe it we did and here's what google
says
when you
search can men menstruate having a
period is not a feminine thing and
people of all genders menstruate
including non-binary people agender
people and even plenty of men
exclamation point
menstruation doesn't change anything
about your gender it's just a thing that
some bodies do
that is pure
bull [ __ ] if blood started pouring
out of my genitals this would be a
problem and it would have nothing to do
with menstruation